عادة ما يكون هذا الفندق ممتلئًا
بالعائلات أو المسافرين من رجال الأعمال ، ولكن الآن
تم تحويله بشكل أساسي
إلى جناح للشفاء لمرضى فيروس كورونا
، وهو أول فندق في المملكة المتحدة يقوم
بذلك ، ولكن قد
يكون قريبًا نموذجًا لتوفير سعة المستشفى الثمينة.
المدخل سيأتون
بسيارة الإسعاف ، حسنًا ،
الضرائب ، حسنًا ، سيكون هذا هو المدخل الخلفي
حيث
سننتظرهم بالطبع ، لا يُسمح لنا برؤية
المرضى بأنفسنا ، لذلك نحن فقط
نلقي نظرة على ما ستكون عليه الغرفة النموذجية
الغرض  من هذا التمرين
للعزل الذاتي ، لذا بمجرد
نقل مريض الخروج المبكر إلى فندق ، سيُنصح
بشدة بالبقاء في الغرفة ، ونحن فخورون جدًا بأن
نكون جزءًا من هذا ،
لذلك من الجيد جدًا أن تكون
جزءًا  لشيء
لدينا ppe كامل وجميع موظفينا على
الأرجح مدربون ، لقد قمنا بالفعل
بزيارة أحد ممتلكاتنا
وقمنا بعمل
مقاطع الفيديو لغرض تدريب
الموظفين هل شعر أي من موظفيك
بالذهول  أحمر أن يكون لدينا مرضى فيروس كورونا
أه هم ليسوا خائفين ، الشعور هو
أننا في الواقع
فخورون بدخول هذه الشراكة مع
ثقة nhs ، هناك ثلاثة مرضى
يتعافون من فيروس كورونا
ورائي هنا الآن لا يوجد عاملين طبيين
في الفندق ،
وهذا يعني أنهم  يتعين عليهم الاتصال إذا كانوا
بحاجة إلى أي مساعدة ويتم توصيل وجبات الطعام
بدون تلامس ثلاث
مرات في اليوم ، لكن إدارة الفندق
يريدون رؤية المزيد من مرضى فيروس كورونا الذين تم
إرسالهم إلى هنا ، فهم يريدون
ملء كل هذه الغرف الفارغة ومع
تأرجح المستشفيات على حافة الهاوية
قد يكون مسؤولو الصحة قريبًا
لأخذهم على هذا العرض
بعض تلك cnn لندن